the date that you brought that your lady
back there come on yes that's Pandora's
Chic right there she stole the spotlight
from you we're talking about you yes
we're talking about you you look
gorgeous we can't not talk about you so
um Sam you recently talked about the
fact that James kind of wrote a an
avatar 1.5 for you guys to kind of get
back into Jake and the Terry what were
they up to in those 10 years in that in
that pre-script it just filled in a lot
of you know a lot of the battle a lot of
the love affair continuing
um I think it was more just for him to
get back in touch with these characters
so he could continue the story anything
that you read that that made you kind of
be like huh okay yeah a lot but I don't
think the boss will let me share it okay
all right
um you uh he also said that I guess
three four and five threes already
completely shot four is partially shot
five is written we had Kate Winslet join
the cast for this one is there anybody
that you would just love to see join you
know one of these casts in one of these
next films I know there's a bunch of new
characters that come into three because
we film scenes with them
um I can't give away who they are but
they're very exciting actors that I get
the privilege to work with so I was
extremely humbled by the new additions
okay so will I be like ah or oh yeah
both okay all right really really good
okay so what can we tease about where we
will see your character go in avatar 3.
the movie's about you know love and it's
about protecting what you love be it the
environment be it your family that's
what it's about yeah
so we will just see him continue to
evolve as a dad and a husband and all of
them
okay real quick you guys did get two
Golden Globe nominations this morning
your react
um look there's thousands of people
involved in this I'm a very small Cog so
it's a great Testament to everybody's
hard work and the creative Endeavors and
time that people have took away from
their family and put into this into this
labor of love it's great
[Music]
thank you